there's no rage at the at the poisoning
of our food or our water syst there's
just not a lot of it you know what
people really get upset about the money
they pay to change their
flight they hate that the least
interesting most banale people on Earth
are only concerned with telling you how
they beat a corporation out of a little
bit of money so that's really what it
come it's just an economic analysis
across the board of most things it's not
quality of life it's not longevity or
whatever it's like I beat the I beat
them there was an extra mozzarella
sticking this I won I had a friend who
was telling I two people sing in my
house one of my friends was telling the
other this guy didn't even know him my
friend's little brother say with me this
guy's going uh let me tell you about the
flight change my friend's little
brother's going what